know if they never got out of the UFC  and had a non-compete my prediction but  I really think he would go into the the  music business I think he was promoting  fights because his love of Music really  oh what kind of music he loves it all  man from rat he loves dirty metal head  banging really something mosh pits  before him been caught on camera  and people don't know he comes into the  arena on show day and makes them play  everybody's walkout song and then he  will tell them a little more bass a  little less trouble yeah he's cut the  walk-off song he did that to me before  Brazil called me he can't come after  that too boring no no he goes too  friendly yeah uh okay I I came out to a  song he called me did the same thing and  and but I mean he is a sound guy he  fancies himself is that he is that